I want to talk about the secrets of
scaling paid ads no matter what business
level you're at biggest obstacle is just
throw ads going down you spend more
money 10 million
ads very low trust and that's
it so I said a bunch of businesses at
different sizes ask me questions about
their paid ads and I'm going to do my
very best to answer them so from you
know $10 million a year all the way down
to $600,000 a year in terms of size some
people are trying to start running paid
ads some people are trying to expand or
scale their ads and are running into
particular issues 650 Dental recruiting
how do I start marketing so you
currently run ads for job boards where
you at raise your hand there you go so
you run ads on job board so you already
know how to run ads all right this is me
trying to break a belief for you so
you're already do it you're just doing
it on another platform all right so
you're doing it in order to get
dentists but you're also trying to
attract dentists who have clinics I
don't think it's you just happen to be
on job boards but fundamentally um you
can run the I mean dentists are also on
meta same thing uh they're probably
older more boring I said that with love
to dentists uh so I would look yeah
Instagram Facebook will probably do
really really well for you and just
saying hey I have a like tired of taking
all these calls yourself like talk to
the pain point of that dentist so it's
like they don't want to work weekends
they don't want to work early hours they
don't want to take cases they don't want
to take well or they don't want to um
they want to eventually retire someday
but they don't want to let down all
their patients and they don't want to
sell us in private Equity because
they're going to force them to work for
5 years in servitude and control their
lives so these are the pain points right
um bless cousins a dentist that's fresh
on my mind uh and so these are all the
pains that's my hook for the ads and
then targeting take your customer list
make it look like audience off that list
if dentist is in the copy dentist is in
the video the AI on Facebook will also
notice Ser it to dentist and it'll be
pretty straightforward
Bingo all right uh 600k acupuncture
start okay so if you want to run so this
is local right okay so the nice thing is
that local business businesses are the
easiest business to run ads for okay
because trust is Skyhigh and you're like
oh they're they don't trust me like try
and sell Beauty to you know people on
the Internet it's much harder um so all
you need to do is run Legion ads so I'm
going to give you the simplest strategy
for getting this are you guys
technically proficient you are okay
fantastic I was going to assume you
weren't and give you an even easier way
um but all you want to do is you can
just run lead ads okay for some sort of
free thing and you're like I want really
high quality people well welcome to cold
traffic so uh they won't be but what you
will need to create is a sales process
that creates qualified customers all
right and so when I say creates it's
really just filters for good ones just
think about it like that it's just like
I'm adding filters uh and the more
filters you add the more expensive the
leads will be if they're good filters
and if they're more expensive they'll be
good if they're good filters if you add
bad filters they'll be more expensive
but they won't be better so if I make it
really hard for my page to load it adds
friction but it's not good friction if I
add a vsl so video sales letter to a
page it'll create friction but it'll be
good friction so I'll increase the
quality of the lead by doing that and so
with a local business you're going to
want to have like in larger National
companies this is where brand adding the
building trust adding Value First
matters in local it matters
significantly less it is very offer
driven on a local basis because people
know what acupuncture is so you can say
free thing or $19 thing since you
probably your time costs a little bit
more than maybe a low skilled labor uh
job I'd probably go for the to $999
thing maybe somewhere in there if I had
to Bet 19 to 29 would be where I'd start
and what you do is you sell people on
that they opt in for it thank you page
they can purchase it you still call all
the leads yourself you close them on the
$19 thing to get a card on file when you
schedule you'll confirm that appointment
and that that card's attached to that
person and so then you'll do the
treatment that you're going to do and
then you're going to sell them the plan
afterwards okay now now my preference
here would be that you sell before you
treat if that doesn't work out for you
you can treat first I just prefer to
have someone in pain sell them the much
longer thing that's going to permanently
solve it give them short-term relief
afterwards and set their next visit and
then on the like when you do your actual
sales appointment the nice thing is you
already have the card and so you can say
awesome so this is this do you want to
use the card you have on file great and
that's the sale does that make sense
okay that's the acupuncture process all
right 3 million CrossFit coach business
coach uh brand conscious so you guys are
doing what kind of cont you guys
making oh podcast is the the only thing
okay so you guys are doing podcasts and
that's it we some longer
cont okay got it okay um the business
started from the podcast the podcast was
first yeah
understood uni personalities yeah are
you guys um barbell uh Shrugged he was
that was yours okay got it yeah yeah
okay okay I hear you um I never had a
name to a face but I knew the podcast
okay so where would I start okay first
thing I would do same thing earlier is I
would do a retargeting campaign across
all platforms and the nice thing is that
platforms are not super hard to figure
out they're made zillions of dollars to
make them easy to click if you already
have traffic so you install a pixel for
each of the platforms on your page
you'll start collecting data from every
single visit that's already coming from
your podcast you can start retargeting
so that's layer one you should probably
also earn your PPC terms it'll
immediately make money like there's no
PPC campaign for your own terms that
doesn't make money I haven't seen it
ever happen my entire life um so that's
number one and two so own your own terms
do the retargeting um third thing is you
have to come up with something that's
really Banger and like super super
valuable that you can give away for free
um like you've seen my stuff so the the
money models books the um the the
framework the 11 Frameworks for
profitable gyms all that stuff so really
put time into it because I think people
really skimp on this and that's why
people opt in they see it they're like
oh this is why would I continue to
book with this person right and so they
opt in thank you page schedule it still
works now the thing is is that you guys
do have a brand if you're worried about
being brand conscious all you do is just
be true to you in the ads and my
recommendation is let your clients talk
so just let proof do the talking that's
how I would approach it um when I look
at all the ads that we've done over the
years like I said earlier 80% of them
are about proof and so as much as we
want to think it's all about us like no
one cares like Alex had the big gym I
still do right the big gym company one
I'm not in the ads anymore at all and I
wasn't for the last two years and it was
because we just focused on the customers
because gym owners don't really care
about me I mean they care about making
money and they're like I'm glad he
helped but really they just want to make
more and see other people like them that
they can say oh this is a good
approximation of my gym and so the idea
there is you want to create the most
compelling proof as possible which is
the type of proof would that would be
the least likely to be faked so on this
extreme you'd have a faceless Anonymous
10-year outdated text based
testimonial on this extreme I would have
someone walk up on stage who looks just
like you owns a CrossFit uh business
coaching business and says Alex help me
go from 3 million to 30 million you'd be
like and I'd be like cool so you'd
be like that's a really good
approximation really hard to Juke right
here live in front of me not recorded in
person specific to me and so that's kind
of the Continuum when you're showing
proof and every approx every every
takeaway it's like okay iners is better
than um than virtual uh live is better
than recorded uh like me is better than
doesn't look like me uh the result that
I want is better than a result that's
close to what I want and so you just
look at all of the factors that make
something super compelling and when
you're looking at your proof kind of
think through it that checklist and
that'll make more compelling proofs that
make more compelling ads that you only
lose trust in the marketplace when you
say something that isn't true and if
you're not saying it and it's their fact
of life
how can anyone fault
you yep 800k vacation rentals B2B so
you're trying to get people who have uh
properties to list with you so that you
can make more money with their
properties for them okay so this will be
really really easy to advertise because
your fundament so do you want people who
already okay you don't want the extra
room people you want the people who have
properties that are being mismanaged
we target homeowners who have a
secondary home that they only use a
couple weeks okay and don't do anything
in the meantime exactly okay so um I
would start
with so my so one I would probably still
use meta as my first bet just because
the targeting there is going to be
easier to figure out um the ads
themselves are going to be the same
thing lead with pain like I was saying
with the dentist is what is the pain of
that person which is do you feel like
you're wasting money money by having
your house sit empty every year as or
every month as you keep paying your
mortgage on something that doesn't get
you a return right it'd be something to
that degree you would know the pain
better than me but that's what I would
imagine the pain would look like um and
so what I would then do is I would send
probably five case studies of different
representative houses and different
representative avatars so kind of the
point I was making there with the
CrossFit gym owners is that in the thing
that I want to send is like we're going
to give you an estimate in the meantime
I'm going to show you 10 representative
types of homes that you can probably
find one that's close to yours so you
can have some reasonable expectation of
what you could potentially earn
switching to shortterm in the meantime
and at the bottom I have the commonly
asked questions which is are these
people going to trash my place what are
you know what's my security going to
look like uh how what if they don't
leave uh cleaning blah blah blah like
all the questions that are going to be
there and I answered that in the bottom
there because we already solved this we
do this with this many homes proof um
and so we've been doing this for this
long more proove and so if you'd like we
can give you an estimation of what we
think based on your neighborhood your
zip code and we can personalize our
process to you great okay that's the ad
uh and the case study that you give them
so free download thank you page
scheduler very simple if you want you
can add an application if you get too
many app if you get too many opt-ins
that aren't qualified you can add more
friction so just for everyone it's like
what's the perfect funnel if you get too
many that are bad add friction if you
don't get enough remove friction and if
you have almost no friction and there's
still bad leads the targeting is off
okay uh 2 million Beauty 4.6 Riz meta
okay you guys are in Columbia you're
shutting down the other two countries
that aren't working as well you're set
you're 30 the 30% you're at 4.6 why
aren't you scaling is the question so
the question like what is the actual
question
here we really want to scale like five
the next the revenue okay and we want to
increase our o okay so how would you
like uh plan the strategy to do that
we're currently making like 100% only in
meta ads great maybe Test new creatives
new platforms but how would you the
strategy the team to do that the content
creation MH because that's like a new
level that we're not yeah so two ways
that you can scale the row at so one is
spend more obviously so I'm not even
including that but in terms of improving
your row as itself it means you either
have to drive down CAC or increase uh
LTV right or average average car value
so in terms of driving now CAC what I
would do is I would look at the top you
probably run a th000 ads over the last
year look at the top 10% or 5% of ads
look at the first 3 seconds of each of
those ads and see if you can model those
three seconds with all of the remaining
ads that you have you can even slice
that first three seconds off of the best
winners and past it on to another 100
plus ads so that'll get you 10 50 times
more ad creative per good winner that
you get so you can squeeze more out of
it so that's from the creative strategy
to drive down ad cost from the uh LTV
perspective um are you guys selling are
you guys selling subscriptions or you
just selling we sell like devices and
also Cosmetics so we have an IPL remal
device we have led mask we have led like
devices uh we also you sell bundles
compl there are Cosmetics to those
devices okay and you sell so you sell
the devices and then the recurring goal
is that people buy the uh order devices
because those are almost like a one time
purchase only yeah that's what I'm
saying so they one time purchase on the
devices but the uh gels or lotions and
Potions go to on a recurring basis right
I mean that's not our main focus because
they like low ticket yeah I got you the
nice thing is that when it's low ticket
when someone buys a high ticket the
likel they buy the low ticket thing if
you bundle it up is pretty high so if
someone buys $1,000 I know what's the
cost like $80 that a high ticket for
that's fine okay so if you have an $80
thing then you could still sell a $40
annual for 12 packs of the creams or
whatever that go with it you just need
to sell a whole bundle of that because
think about it from the consumer if I'm
buying it's because I believe that I'm
going to do this and if I am going to do
it then I might as well get the savings
on the stuff that goes with it like if I
buy a printer and someone says Hey buy a
Year's worth of Inc and you in the m in
the moment you're like well I am going
to print stuff that's why I'm buying it
then and not everyone's going to take it
but if 30% of people take it you add 12
bucks to your to your uh ACV and right
there you've got whatever that is 15% um
that you add so that's one thing um in
ter do you have payment plans and
financing set up uh yeah okay so that's
good um the big thing with I mean I
would still I would lean harder on that
thing that I'm talking about with the
the CP like think about the other think
about the other things that someone who
purchases this uh machine is going to
want to buy and still offer it like
there's no point and then just think
about doing it in bundles rather than
one-offs because one-offs aren't going
to make a difference but bundling for
the the year will'll multiply this with
any of those small knickknacks buy a lot
so you might even be able to double for
like the max cart might be able to you
know double how much someone spends um
and you'll feel those pops so I think
between those two things but I think as
a quick word of advice um you guys are
in the beauty director consumer business
you are a marketing company and so
doubling down on Creative as a
discipline is what's going to separate
you from like if you want to get to 20
million a year it's going to be you
doing 10 times or 50 times more cre
cretive in terms of what you're putting
out for output and so that means being
having a better system for both
capturing ugc and then repurposing ugc
and so for us for context we spend 80%
of our resources taking winners and just
reskinning them 80% and so you're
getting all these new ads but the the
real money is okay I have this one
winner and um I had I'll give you a
story I had an ad that we called the
kale ad so kale is our our GM right and
he made this ad before he was the GM and
it was this beautiful this perfect
testimonial and he couldn't have planned
it any better he had like the gym behind
him he had his wife with him he was like
we were two months from shutting our
doors you can see the gym full he's like
and within four months it was completely
full 18 months I had it you know six
months I had it completely outsourced by
18 months I sold the whole gym and I was
losing money and I was working a
full-time job just to pay the bills at
the gym and you know this many months
later it was all great right now when we
had that ad I made about a hundred
versions of that ad so I made a black
and white version I did a sepia filter
version I reordered the back end um we
swapped out hooks I put different
headlines I put different subheads I
changed the fonts I did I ran it with
different ad copy I will use and abuse
it until it doesn't work at all and so
when you have your winners you usually
just need to run them way longer way
harder in a lot of different variations
so you can squeeze way more out of
it feel good cool all right uh 1.8
Private Practice
okay so the question what was the
question on this you want to scale it oh
the the lead ma okay yes so right now
you've ran your ads to application so
opt-in application and that didn't work
and then you go freebies to book a call
and that's not working because your call
team sucks we running freebie to get
people inside Facebook group okay and
then having a trying to set the calls
from the group okay we're have a lot of
capacity for the to set more calls to
more sales so we wanted to do something
that was more directly to book
callip the process sure
time so it works it's just
expensive um okay so I'll give you what
I know from group funnels that run on
school all the time and so there's four
conversion processes from a group so one
is that you add a free onboarding call
to the free group so every single person
that gets added to the group gets an odd
Morning Call as a bonus for joining the
group on the odd morning call you then
clarify where they there label no
problem over their past experiences oh I
think you might be a good fit can I tell
you about it Grant okay cool then you
sell them into the into the other thing
um the second way is that you put uh
five video series inside of the group
that functions as a vssl but just broken
up and so you introduce the opportunity
your core Story the big idea and then
you do three stories which are going to
be their biggest belief breaking points
so big issue one big issue two big issue
three which is typically Universe other
people in self and break down all three
of those and then on the end you'll make
your call to action which is the fifth
video which is a little bit of Stack a
little bit of Sizzle and you make the
CTA the third one is that inside of that
group you'll do a weekly webinar where
you provide value for the majority of
the webinar and you soft toss the CTA
your sales guys and sets are on that
webinar anybody who chats in there they
can pull off if somebody's like oh man I
got this question oh that was so
valuable they immediately DM them and
pull them off the call and then they can
set them right there the fourth way is
that anybody who engages on recordings
or posts inside the group grou likes
comments or makes a post the DM Setters
go in and then set the call so it's four
different ways that you can set from the
group and if you're driving all your
traffic there and it is working you just
probably need to train your Setters
better and maybe have more of them yep
all right uh 1.2 million VA so you want
to start running ads for your VA
business to get business
owners yes sir
okay what type of va so it's a virtual
assistant either primary secondary
United States we can do estimates credit
cards
calls for service based companies estim
so like Home
Services okay so you're looking for
service business owners like ruing right
to hire vas to do some of the leg work
for their team okay so the good news is
that Home Services is pretty easy to
Target um with ads I would probably also
start on meta there um just cuz meta
targeting really is probably the easiest
Tik Tok is pretty good targeting too
it's getting much much much better but I
would start with meta so Facebook and
Instagram um and again the the funnels
here are
just really valuable thing for how many
how many clients do you have okay you
have 70 clients and so what I would want
to do is show how much money they save
and how much more profit they make per
roofer and I would just literally
explain it a lot of people won't know so
be like the average roofer or the
average home service person who has
Tradesmen who are going out are spending
this much per hour to have the person do
that do estimates do card checks do
whatever the three main things that you
do and that means that per person it's
costing you $25,000 a year in labor all
right now the thing is is that for $500
a month we can replace this so take
25,000 and instead pay six per year so
you get the spread you get $199,000 back
per person and so if You' like to see
how we can help you implement this we
will guarantee this result um and by day
90 if you haven't made at least five
times the money that we've done we'll
give you the rest of the year of the vas
for
free that would be my offer the actual
creative would be you breaking down the
process and what you want to do is have
some sort of visual proof that's like
this is what JN did and JN made this
much you know saved this much money
here's Stu and Stu saved this much and
just say the size of the business so
he's doing about $10 million a year he's
got 20 guys and this is what he was able
to save so if these numbers sound at
least interesting to you we'd be happy
to hop on a call if you have a two call
close you can say you can leave your
credit card home it's just to make sure
it's a fit for us as much as it fit for
you we only take roofers above a certain
size so if you are smaller don't worry
we'll send you with some resources that
can help you out for free but if you are
above a size we might be able to help
you out and either way it would be
another call for us to close so you can
relax it's not a sales call cool so add
with that kind of copy and messaging and
then freebie thing that will also be a
longer version of that with maybe some
writing that gives some graphs and some
visuals or whatever and then you can
have the thank you page scheduler uh for
them to book a call still outbound dial
all the people you have some vas I'm
sure they can do that call all the leads
that opt in no matter what and the nice
thing with that is that if your vas are
good then they can be like I'm a VA I
could be doing this for you that would
be my
script okay
yep do you have an email
list yeah so if you have an email list
of over a thousand I'm assume you do um
you can take that list and then put a
look like audience and start there as
you're targeting cuz that be the issue
for you in the beginning yep and make
that the headline like home service
providers okay uh 1.2 million in solar
what now 7 plus row as things are
working I'm going to tell you where are
you I'm going to tell you to spend more
all right so what's the
problem expanding like do I continue
creating and tting ads
or
8020 % the budget testing
80% yeah so Google already really
experimented with this so the the
technical one is the better one is 70210
so 70% is doing the main thing so just
the one ad that you have 20% is adjacent
to that so as many different ways as you
can think of you know versions of it
that's not that at so everything that I
see as permutations of that I see as the
70 adjacent to that similar in style is
the 20 10 is just wild ass ideas of
maybe this would would work and so
that's how you allocate resources and
I'm being super real so if you spend a
whole day making ads so you spend eight
hours that means you're going to do 1
hour 45 minutes on your one idea and
then you're going to spend two plus
hours on adjacent ideas and then the
entire rest of the day is on how many
different ways can I make the same ad
per and that's how you allocate time
it's the same way we allocate time when
we make ads we look up all the top
winners we start with all those we
hammer out all that stuff because that's
our real work that's the bread and
butter then we move one that way I said
it in reverse in terms of order for the
day but fundamentally I want to get the
70 done first the 20 done second and if
I've got time and I'm feeling energy
I'll do the
third all
right so $1.2 million in Assisted Living
Facebook and YouTube they're getting 20
to1 row as the thing that you guys
should do is spend more money because
you have eight spots left in your
assisted living and you're getting 20
to1 and you should be okay with doing
that as long as you have capacity if you
know what your rate of filling people up
is then you can dial the spend so that
you can keep it so it's smooth now if
you're losing money every month that
those things aren't full then I would
crank it and then turn it off if you
want the weight list thing I would know
that I only need three people or four
people on the weit list that they have
to pay in order to be on the weit list
otherwise it's not a weit list it's just
like telling someone to go away and then
assuming they're going to you know care
about you when they when you call back
even though they've already solved the
problem uh because they're probably in a
market and want to you move within a
certain number of months CU someone's in
pain when I say pain it's a pain in the
ass to deal with somebody who's you know
you're trying to put into that and so
that is what I would do if I were in
your particular situation and I would go
get investors so you can open up more
locations faster check all right ding
ding ding all right so $10 million
Executive Health the running YouTube ads
are getting 10 to one these guys are
spending $1,000 a month to make $10,000
back even though they're doing a
million-ish a month on their main
business so that means 1% of their
revenue comes from their YouTube ads and
the question is how do we scale the main
problem is compliance
and so they're in a health space and so
a lot of the issues in health sometimes
wealth even relationship stuff is the
claims that you make and being able to
support them and so number one is there
are firms that specialize in compliance
Audits and so I go like if we have an
issue like one of our it happens all the
time right ads get shut down because
there's all these different automated
things even if you're doing nothing
wrong so you go to these firms and
usually just ask them what their
approval rating is uh post compliance
usually it's 90% Plus for the good ones
it doesn't cost that much it's like five
or six grand and they'll go through the
audit all the sites the audit all the
the videos and collateral that you use
so that then you can resubmit and they
usually have some sort of in internal
Google kind of back door where they say
hey we will make sure these people are
compliant they relationship with Google
and uh they can make sure that you get
pushed through so usually un as long as
you're not doing anything completely
racy which I'm guessing you're not um
you should be fine great $10 million
Roofing PPC so you want to expand so
you're spending $30,000 a month which
row as 71 okay 71 row as $10 million a
month Roofing doing PPC wants to expand
and you're in a local market okay so if
you're trying to expand there first
campaign I would run would be a
retargeting across all platforms so I
would be retargeting on gdn so Google
Display Network I'd be retargeting on
Instagram i' retar on Facebook um I'd be
retargeting on YouTube anyone who's done
a site visit that'll be the first and
easiest Riz that you can get because
you've already paid for it so consider
that like the shadow funnel which is
whenever you blow traffic through
anything you should always have Global
retargeting across all platforms because
then you can scoop up everything else
and it almost always is positive roas so
number one um number two if I had to
pick another um platform I would
actually do meta um because obviously
PPC have super high intent so the lead
quality is going be lower on meta
because it's Interruption based
marketing rather than tent based
marketing um because people aren't
looking for it when they're scrolling on
Facebook but a lot of older people are
on meta so Facebook especially but
Instagram too Instagram's got the whole
the whole gamut right and so people who
have roofs uh to fix and so I actually
think it'll be fine that Facebook's
aging up a little bit for you to run ads
there and since the average ticket's so
high in Roofing um you'll probably good
in terms of the funnel um typically like
free audits or some sort of free thing
is good enough um and you can talk to
them about savings that they're going to
make if they fix the roof uh in terms of
heating cooling all the other Jazz that
you guys do um and you can basically do
that for free you can send someone out
you can do it virtually and then
probably two call close so set close
after the freebie freebie is the first
page call thing is the second page call
all people who opt in for the freebie to
confirm the call that they did and if
they didn't book set the call and then
close on the call that's actually booked
so if they book for Wednesday call them
anyway today confirm qualify if you
don't have time to set it well you will
have time cuz you're setting it set it
and then close on the appointment on
Wednesday so it can speed up the sales
cycle great real estate long-term
rentals investment interesting stuff
um so rowes is down trust is down
unsurprising um and so the question that
you have is how do you increase Ro and
build trust for this client so um
there's two ways that I can think of so
one is making content long term is what
adds is what grows the organic audience
it's what allows a lot of people here to
even have the business they have and
you'd be surprised it is slower but over
time it does compound and it becomes a
pretty big stream and if you know how to
run ads and you can make content that's
what makes you a weapon because it's
like it's crazy when you can do both
second thing um focus more on proof not
on promise everyone makes promises very
people have proof so proof so if you
think about this this is a little little
sound bite for you
your promise is not unique your proof is
everyone in the marketplace promises the
same thing the question is whether they
can back it up and that is unique to you
and so if you want to have a more unique
place in the mark in the market have
more proof not a different promise
fundamentally like all gym owners want
to make more money most business owners
want to make more money or they want to
save time or they want to save headache
or whatever it is like the promises
aren't going to be that different the
thing that will differentiate you will
be the mechanism how believable it is
which will be a function of the proof
and the the way that you're describing
it if you're like oh we have this brand
new personal training model where you do
six personal training sessions up front
and then you get them into this and look
at the economics behind it people stay
way longer it's like oh that's a unique
mechanism and it's like okay that sounds
like it's different than what I did but
how do I know it works cool here's a
hundred stories of people who were in
your exact position that made it work
right so proof is going to be the main
thing now the other way that you can
build trust um beyond the proof is you I
think group funnels right now work
really really well I I think that
they're going to I mean the reason I
invest in school because I think that
um but group funnels are like routinely
getting people from like $250 calls to
like $40 calls and I'm seeing this like
over and over again across Industries
and so the way that these funnels work I
already talked about the conversion
mechanisms earlier but you use the free
group as a lead magnet so that becomes
the lead magnet and the nice thing is
that it it functions basically like an
email list with long-term nurture but
it's way more engaging than an email
list is um and so people who use the
group funnels uh right now just to give
you a metric to this also for you for
the groups it's 10% so the guys who do
do a good job convert 10% of people who
opt in uh to the group into their their
next level thing and so most people are
able to close 30 to 50% of calls they
get on and so you can Target getting on
call with onethird of the people who opt
in for the group and closing between 30
and 50% so if you get on call with 30%
and you close a third you get 10% of the
group depending obviously there's some
Flex on skill there um but that's kind
of just some benchmarks that you can
that you can look at but those the three
things so add more proof make more
content consider a group
funnel
boom all
[Applause]
right thank